according to several reports circulating
in the UK press this morning UK
authorities are now looking at five
possible suspects in this [ __ ]
poisoning saga we are waiting for more
details on that to be revealed that is
yet to come we have contacted Scotland
Yard who have told us that they don't
really have any news to share and that
they're continuing to pursue several
lines of inquiry now at the same time we
are seeing uk-based open source
investigative team Belling cat
announcing that they have according to
them conclusively identified the third
suspect in this [ __ ] poisoning case
if you remember previously they said
that according to them the names of the
first two suspects are chip Wigan and
wish Kim they identified those two men
as GRU officers now they're saying that
this third suspect is a 45 year old
Sergey fedora
who according to Belen cat is a senior
GRU officer bill and cat are saying that
all of these three men had their covers
created at the same in the same year
back in 2010 and according to them this
third suspect is linked to a case in
2015 in Bulgaria where a businessman
fell sick and was taken to hospital
along with a son and his executive and
the story they're never led to nor the
chalk and the substance used on him was
not really identified but Belling cat is
now linking those together and we have
heard from the Kremlin spokesperson say
that it's not really clear where this
connection comes from and what this
revelation is based off of we can get
some insight now from author and Russia
analyst Martyn McCauley Martin thanks
for coming onto the programme now there
were lots of question marks hanging over
a lot of the claims the first time
around in the scrap pile case as it
proved hard to find that definitive
information what can respect expect this
time is there anything concrete that we
can have more insight into what's
happened
I think it's an ongoing saga because
after the identified
- apparently giu officers last year
there were rumors there were two more
involved and now we hear this five three
more in salons an ongoing saga and it's
quite interesting that they're linking
these officers to Bulgaria because one
thinks back in the Soviet era when yoga
Markov was murdered and he was a
Bulgarian and therefore in the in the
British mind when you think about
Bulgaria you think if Sergey Markov who
was murdered in London with an umbrella
poisoned with an umbrella and therefore
the the average Briton reading that and
thinking about that ah yes that makes
sense because Margot was murdered in
London and that went back to the KGB in
Moscow so therefore it's probable now
that there was some link to this [ __ ]
case in other words it's it's conspiracy
and people love conspiracies and all
this conspiracy causes pods the fingered
Moscow all the time
and it's no accident that it's come at
present because the United States is
leaving the INF treaty and therefore
Russian is being accused of a whole
variety of things of in fact violating
the INF treaty that's bad news for
Moscow this is more bad news for Moscow
and because we've got brexit in Britain
and perhaps the authorities thought yeah
there's an interesting time to bring
this item up with the present because
they're not going to give any definitive
information because they would then be
revealing their sources but why not
bring it up at present because let's
divert some attention away from BRICS it
not in the script pal case though it's
been in the spot line for some time now
considering the length and the depth of
the initial investigation and all the
controversy that that entailed into the
Salisbury attack why hadn't this
information emerge before do you think
I think it's an ongoing one because from
the security services point of view they
think in the long term they will they
will look into this case and they will
investigate it because they haven't
really identified everything that they
need to identify they've made
accusations and so on which are really
impossible to prove and you cannot go
back and find the the the officer or the
government official of the government
minister or even the president who gave
the order so therefore you keep looking
and trying to find more information so
you build up a network of contacts and
people giving giving orders and in this
way you keep this subject live because
in the public public's imagination this
was this is a huge story and it's still
going on and script pal is still not
well and he hasn't been released and so
on so he's still ill so therefore in the
public eye this story is still live and
will continue to alive and it will do a
lot of damage to Bangla Russian
relations as it continues but from
Security's point of view security
services point of view they will
continue this because they're looking
and finding if they can find more
contacts if they can link these officers
to other attacks in other countries then
the bill builds up a network of
information which they can use at
present and hopefully in the future ok
author in Russia and there's Martin
McCauley thanks very much for coming on
to the program thank you
you